مقامره ماسك منصه كتويتر عرضتها لهجره
العقول وخساره المستخدمين هو الاخطر
خلافات مع افضل العلامات التجاريه
والمسوقين فالعهد المطرب لتويتر عرض قسم
الاعلانات لدى الشركه الذي يجني 5 مليارات
دولار سنويا الى ضربه قويه
جميع العلامات التجاريه الكبرى اوقفت
مؤقتنا الانفاق على تويتر مستشهدين بالجزع
من نهج ماسك بمراقبه المحتوى وفصل العديد
من فريق مبيعات الاعلانات قسم الاعلانات
بتويتر تعرض ايضا لضربه
موجات من عمليات الفصل والاستقالات ادت
لنقص حاد بالموظفين وباتت العديد من
الوكالات لا تملك نقطه اتصال مع تويتر
ماسك المرغم على اتمام صفقه تويتر يجد
نفسه تحت ضغوط تحقيق الاردادات حيث يواجه
مدفوعات بفائده سنويه بقيمه مليار دولار
بعد تحميل الشريكه بدي قدره 13 مليار
دولار للمساعده في تمويل استحواذ على
الشركه رغم تلك الحقائق كلها لا يزال
الملياردير ينظر بتفاؤل للعصفور الازرق
ويغرد عبره بابرز انجازاته على صعيد
المستخدمين يقول ماسك ان تسجيلات
المستخدمين الجدد بلغت اعلى مستوياتها
بمتوسط اكثر من مليونين شخص يوميا في
الايام السبعه الماضيه اعتبارا من السادس
عشر من نوفمبر وبالنسبه 66% مقارنه
بالاسبوع نفسه من العام الماضي وما يقرب
من ثمانيه مليارات دقيقه الناشطه يوميا
للمستخدمين في الايام السبعه الماضيه
اعتبارا من ال 15 من نوفمبر وبالنسبه 30%
مقارنه بنفس الاسبوع من العام الماضي اما
خطاب الكراهيه على تويتر فبات اقل بقرابه
الثلث اعتبارا من الثالث عشر من نوفمبر
مقارنه بمنتصف اكتوبر من العام الماضي
بانخفاض من 10 ملايين الى مليونين ونصف
المليون الا ان النظر تتفاؤليه لالون ماسك
تجاه منصته الرقميه كانت تناقض ارقاما
اخرى فقد كشفت تقرير لمركز مكافحه
الكراهيه الرقبيه ان استخدام الاهانات
العنصريه على تويتر ارتفع ثلاثه اضعاف
مقارنه بالاعوام السابقه منذ استحواذ الى
الماسك على المنصه واتهم الاتحاد الاوروبي
وتويتر بالفشل في ازاله خطاب الكراهيه
[موسيقى]